Revisor: Sebastian Betti
Cuando estaba en cuarto de primaria, mi maestro nos dijo un día:
"Hay tantos números pares como números.
"¿De verdad?", me dije. Pues sí, hay infinitos en cada caso, así que supongo que habrá una misma cantidad de ambos.
Pero, por otra parte, los pares son sólo parte de los números enteros; también están los impares,
así que tiene que haber más números enteros que pares, ¿no?
Para ver lo que mi maestro quería decir, pensemos primero en lo que significa que dos conjuntos tengan el mismo tamaño.
¿Qué quiero decir cuando afirmo que tengo el mismo número de dedos en mi mano derecha que en la izquierda?
Está claro que tengo cinco dedos en cada una, pero la cosa es aún más sencilla.
No tengo que contar, me basta con establecer una correspondencia uno a uno entre los dedos de ambas manos.
De hecho, creemos que algunos pueblos antiguos que hablaban idiomas que carecían de palabras
para números mayores de tres usaban este tipo de recurso. Por ejemplo, si sacas las ovejas a pastar desde el redil,
puedes llevar la cuenta de cuántas salieron apartando una piedra por cada una de ellas
y volviéndolas a juntar una a una cuando las ovejas vuelven.
Así sabrías si falta alguna sin tener realmente que contar.
Otro ejemplo de que las correspondencias son más básicas que contar es el siguiente:
si hablo ante un auditorio lleno a rebosar, en el que todos los asientos están ocupados y nadie está de pie,
sé que hay el mismo número de sillas que de personas en el público,
aunque no sepa cuántas hay de unas ni de otras.
Así que, lo que realmente queremos decir cuando afirmamos que dos conjuntos tienen el mismo tamaño
es que entre los elementos de ambos conjuntos se puede establecer alguna correspondencia uno a uno.
Mi maestro de cuarto nos mostró los números enteros en fila, y debajo de cada uno de ellos su doble.
Como pueden ver, la fila de abajo contiene todos los números pares, y tenemos una correspondencia uno a uno.
Así que hay tantos números pares como números.
Pero lo que aún nos incomoda es que parece que los números pares son solo una parte de todos los enteros.
Pero, ¿convence esto de que no tengo los mismos dedos en la mano derecha y en la izquierda?
Por supuesto que no. No importa si uno intenta establecer la correspondencia de alguna manera que no sea válida,
eso no nos convence de nada.
Si uno encuentra una manera de que los elementos de ambos conjuntos se correspondan entre sí uno a uno,
entonces decimos que los dos conjuntos tienen el mismo número de elementos.
¿Pueden hacer una lista de todas las fracciones? Puede que sea difícil, ¡son muchas!
Y no es nada evidente por cuál empezar, o cómo asegurarnos de que en la lista están todas.
Sin embargo, existe una manera muy inteligente de construir la lista de todas las fracciones.
El primero en hacerla fue Georg Cantor, a finales del siglo XIX.
Primero, ponemos todas las fracciones en una cuadrícula. Están todas. Por ejemplo, encontramos 117/243
en la fila 117ª y la columna 223ª.
Ahora creamos la lista empezando por la esquina superior izquierda y recorriéndola diagonalmente una y otra vez,
saltándonos todas las fracciones, como 2/2, que representan números que ya hemos seleccionado.
Tenemos así una lista de todas las fracciones, lo que significa que hemos creado una correspondencia uno a uno
entre los enteros y las fracciones, a pesar de que pensábamos que quizá habría más fracciones.
Ahora es cuando la cosa se pone realmente interesante.
Puede que sepan que no todos los números reales —todos los que figuran en la recta numérica— son fracciones.
Por ejemplo, la raíz cuadrada de dos o pi.
Los números como estos se llaman irracionales. No porque estén locos, sino porque las fracciones son
razones entre números enteros, y por tanto se llaman racionales. Lo que significa que el resto son no racionales, es decir, irracionales.
Los irracionales se representan mediante un número infinito de decimales que no se repiten.
¿Podemos establecer una correspondencia uno a uno entre los enteros y el conjunto de todos los decimales,
racionales e irracionales incluidos? Es decir, ¿podemos hacer una lista de todos los números decimales?
Cantor demostró que no. No que no supiésemos cómo hacerlo, sino que no se podía hacer.
Supongamos que alguien asegura que ha construido una lista de todos los decimales. Voy a demostrar que no es así,
creando un decimal que no está en la lista.
Lo haré cifra a cifra.
Para la primera cifra decimal de mi número, partiré de la primera cifra decimal de ese primer número.
Si es un uno, la mía será un dos; si no lo es, la mía será un uno.
Para la segunda cifra de mi número, me fijaré en la segunda cifra decimal de ese segundo número.
De nuevo, si la de Uds es un uno, la mía será un dos; y si no lo es, la mía será un uno.
¿Ven cómo funciona? El número decimal que he creado no puede estar en esa lista.
¿Por qué? ¿Podría ser, pongamos, el número 143º? No, porque la 143ª cifra decimal de mi número
es distinta de la 143ª cifra de ese 143º número. Así es como la he construido.
La lista es incompleta. No contiene mi número decimal.
Y me des la lista que me des, siempre puedo hacer lo mismo y construir un número que no figure en ella.
Así que llegamos a esta asombrosa conclusión:
Los números decimales no pueden ponerse en una lista. Representan una infinidad mayor que la de los números enteros.
Así que, aunque sólo estamos acostumbrados a ver unos pocos irracionales, como la raíz de dos o pi,
la infinidad de todos los irracionales es de hecho mayor que la de las fracciones.
Alguien dijo una vez que los racionales —las fracciones— son como las estrellas del firmamento;
y los irracionales son la oscuridad.
Cantor también demostró que, para cualquier conjunto infinito, se puede crear un infinito mayor que reúna
todos los subconjuntos del conjunto inicial. Eso significa que, una vez que tengamos un infinito,
siempre podemos crear uno mayor construyendo el conjunto que engloba a todos los subconjuntos del primero.
Y uno aún mayor creando el conjunto de todos los subconjuntos de este segundo. Y así sucesivamente.
Por tanto, hay un número infinito de infinitos de distintos tamaños.
Si estas ideas les incomodan, no son los únicos. Algunos de los más grandes matemáticos de la época de Cantor
estaban muy molestos con estas cosas e intentaron hacer que los distintos infinitos fuesen irrelevantes,
hacer que,, de alguna manera, las matemáticas pudiesen funcionar sin ellos.
Cantor llegó a ser vilipendiado personalmente, y la situación se complicó tanto que cayó en una profunda depresión
y pasó la última mitad de su vida entrando y saliendo de centros psiquiátricos,
Pero, con el tiempo, sus ideas se impusieron y hoy en día se consideran fundamentales y magníficas.
Todos los matemáticos investigadores las aceptan y se estudian en todas las universidades
y yo te las he explicado en apenas unos minutos.
Un día, quizá, formen parte del saber popular.
Hay más. Acabamos de señalar que el conjunto de números decimales —es decir, los números reales— es una
infinidad mayor que el conjunto de números enteros. Cantor se planteó si habría infinitos
de diferentes tamaños entre esos dos. Pensaba que no era así, pero no fue capaz de demostrarlo.
Esta conjetura de Cantor se conoce como hipótesis del continuo.
En 1900, el gran matemático David Hilbert destacó la hipótesis del continuo como el más importante
de los problemas aún por resolver en matemáticas.
El siglo XX fue testigo de la resolución de este problema, pero de una manera completamente inesperada y disruptiva.
En los años veinte, Kurt Gödel demostró que no se puede demostrar que la hipótesis del continuo sea falsa.
Después, en los sesenta, Paul J. Cohen demostró que tampoco se puede probar que sea cierta.
Juntos, ambos resultados implican que en matemáticas hay preguntas para las que no existe respuesta.
Una conclusión realmente asombrosa.
Las matemáticas se consideran, con razón, la cumbre del razonamiento humano
pero ahora sabemos que incluso las matemáticas tienen sus limitaciones.
A pesar de lo cual, siguen proporcionando cosas realmente fascinantes en las que pensar.